[Music]
so don't say you'd use these beans in
your interviews here in the community
yes so the beans were very very
practical and easy tool to quantify
people person perception so if I love
being can represent anything can
represent the total observed population
can represent the total abnormalities
observed in the animals so for example
one of the exercise the beans
represented the total absorption i would
ask in the group setting to divide the
beans into the relative proportion of
adults observed and the young animals so
collaboratively the participants in the
group they should agree on the different
proportion so some of them will divide
they were divided together the beans
that represent what they observe now as
a young animals and what what they would
observe now for adult animals in the
context of the disease the pile of being
could represent the total of normality
of observed in any given point in time
and so they had Alista to combine of the
different diseases and of sign again
relative proportion so they would split
again their pile of beans according to
their relative proportion of the
different abnormalities and I would
measure that with a measurement cup to
have an estimate of their percentage
[Music]